David is an Indianapolis hi David
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up me and my wife have a student
loan issue we had ten separate student
loans with Sallie Mae they were calling
for a couple months we finally started
set up a payment plan but we didn't
notice that they had sold off two loans
to a different student loan company
there's one more of a debt collector
style they garnished her wages just
recently and we're trying to figure out
what the best route would be the loan
balance was originally two twelve
thousand they currently quoted us at 25
and 15 in principle five and interest
five and fees and cost and they said
they'd settle for eighteen I was
wondering if what the best route would
be to if you're thinking in the 18
together I would take it and get it get
it off of get off the garnishment
that'll give you a lot better cash flow
in your situation can you scratch the 18
up we cannot we have been following the
baby steps they've got a thousand-dollar
emergency fund now so you don't really
have the art and of taking the 18 and
inquire about a HELOC against our house
just to get it off of going down I
wouldn't do that I wouldn't do that I
believe it said on garnish but for right
now how much other debt have you got
we have $75,000 in other debt 22 on cars
or on a wedding loan and 50 on other
state loan that we currently on payment
plan it for okay and your household
income is 115 oh that's good news
so you're plowing through this pretty
quick you'll be debt-free in two years
yes sir we were doing really well and we
just got scared by the garnishment yeah
I think it can takes them it takes the
breath out of you it is scary it's
emotional have somebody take over your
life which is what garnishment does yeah
I think regardless of the garnishment if
you just say 37 five a year two years
we're gonna be debt-free making a
hundred you can do that
and I think you're gonna be okay I know
I would not take out a HELOC to get rid
of this it's just the emotional aspect
of it let's just lean in get them
knocked off as fast as you can and work
your debt snowball and be debt-free in
two years this is the Dave Ramsey show